alors je suis très heureux ce soir de
vous parler de ce qui nous anime
effectivement ici à valenciennes alors
dans nos locaux c'est plus simple et je
vais vous parler d'un troisième monde un
peu comme éric julien un monde que j'ai
découvert après une expérience dans le
bâtiment de 8 ans qui s'appelle la
troisième révolution industrielle
troisièmement troisième révolution
industrielle c'est assez similaire est
en fait c'est la compréhension que le
monde actuel est en train de changer
le fait qu' il ya beaucoup de choses qui
vont bouger et je vais essayer de vous
détailler
moi ce que j'ai compris dans ce monde là
alors pour vous expliquer ce que je fais
aujourd'hui je commercialise des
imprimantes 3d ça c'est ce qui nous fait
vivre et avec ça mais équipe et moi même
on développe des solutions 3d variés
dans la médecine dans plein de cas
concrets dans l'industrie est
aujourd'hui et ce soir je vais vous
parler ce qui m'anime le plus c'est une
solution de troisième révolution
industrielle donc l'impression 3d
appliquées au bâtiment alors
l'impression 3d pour ceux qui
connaissent pas c'est les machines qui
peuvent imprimer un peu ce qu'on veut et
moi j'ai découvert ça ya trois ans j'ai
mis la machine sur la table du salon
et j'aime bien raconter cette histoire
parce que c'est mon fils qui met en fait
mis dedans
monfils avait 6 ans et quand on a un
prix mais la première figurine que je
lui demande et enfin vous voulez hein
qu'est ce que tu veut imprimer françois
il m'a dit je veux un dragon papa et on
a un prix mais on à télécharger et
imprimer un dragon quand il a eu dans
les mains c'était pas très joli mais il
m'a dit mais papa c'est génial avec ça
on va avoir plus besoin que d'eau et de
nourriture
alors il avait sa barrière là moi
j'avais ma carrière là et j'essaie de
dire mais et s'il avait raison
et aujourd'hui je me rends compte qu'il
a raison et a fortiori un peu tort parce
qu'on on a des imprimantes à chocolat
vous les verrez peut-être tout à l'heure
et on imprime n'importe quoi l'enjeu
c'est de profiter de cette révolution
industrielle et de ce qu'apporte
l'impression 3d comme outil de la
troisième révolution industrielle pour
aider l'homme et essayer d'en faire
quelque chose d'intéressant socialement
pour changer les choses
alors moi qui fais du bâtiment j'essaye
d'utiliser impression 3d pour le
bâtiment et mes équipes
on a développé un projet ça fait un an
qu'on est dessus et en fait on va
proposer d'imprimer les maisons
l'impression 3d
aujourd'hui enfin l'impression de maison
ça fait un peu sourire
il ya des chinois qui sont dessus des
américains qui sont dessus je vous
expliquais très vite après où ils en
sont et nous en fait on a fait une
petite vidéo pour résumer la date de
janvier et elle résume vraiment ce qu'on
a compris c'est à dire que l'impression
elle doit être local c'est à dire on
doit imprimer la maison là où elle doit
être
on doit utiliser des matériaux de
proximité je vais vous expliquer après
qu'est ce qu'on va utiliser et on doit
aussi respecter les géométries de la
nature sa viande on danse avec ce qu
éric julien vous expliquer
et donc on a créé un prototype virtuel
qu'ils aient pu si virtuelle que ça et
je vous le présente voilà donc ça c'est
une imprimante à béton pour l'instant
c'est du béton et ont la place au milieu
de la construction
et si vous voulez tout l'enjeu c'est ma
d'utiliser le compas comme géométrie de
base pour fabriquer ce qu'on veut
pourquoi le compas ça permet bat déjà de
travailler de l'intérieur
donc on mobilise moins de matériel pour
créer un bâtiment et couche par couche
comme dans l'impression 3d nos petites
machines on dépose de la matière 3 cm 5
cm et petit à petit vous voyez bien que
la maison à l'avance et puis que c'est
automatique on fait la forme qu'on veut
on un design 3d qui sert de source
donc les design 3d ici en 800 étudiants
qui peuvent nous généré chacun une
maison si vous voulez et on peut
intégrer les poteaux pourquoi pas les
escaliers pourquoi pas la piscine et
puis c'est pas trés troisième round
fréhel voilà si on accélère les choses
bon an mal an en moins d'une journée
je vous fais une maison du maître par
dit m ça c'est le deal une journée une
maison une machine si on industrialise
la création de ces machines
imaginez un petit peu ce que ça peut
changer alors il ya plein de choses à
dire autour de ça il faut que ça serve à
l'homme ça c'est le premier enjeu c'est
assez fou pour que ça marche
pour que vous compreniez bien
aujourd'hui on vous a ramené un
prototype alors ça c'est notre prototype
au stade actuel donc excusé un petit peu
l'état de la chose mais demain on en
reçoit notre pompe et on commence les
essais donc on a un petit prototype de
deux mètres et donc c'est le combat que
vous avez vu cinq fois plus petit donc
avec ça on sait déjà imprimé des bancs
on sait un déjà imprimé des vases et des
choses on entre avec du béton pour ça
qu'il ya une buse en béton et ben voila
moi tout l'enjeu c'est d'essayer de ces
réaliser une machine qui va aller plus
loin alors le béton c'est bien pour
commencer parce que c'est facile c'est
l'homogénéité de la matière mais il faut
vraiment utiliser une matière de cycle
court alors l'at il ya des gens qui ont
déjà beaucoup travaillé et notamment un
californien qui m'a beaucoup inspiré qui
s'appelle nader khalili
il est décédé en 2008 mais l'association
qui perdure qui s'appelle california for
her say qui fabrique des dom en terre et
tous les enjeux en fait pour nous c'est
d'automatiser ce qu'il a compris parce
que c'est d'homme il était déjà me la
géométrie parfaite
inspirée de la nature nichoirs
d'hirondelles les les ruches ou ou
tellement de choses en fait
on a complètement oublié cette géométrie
de base qu'on a utilisées dans nos
constructions antiques
le groupe a aussi été antique d'ailleurs
et si vous voulez c'est un peu grâce à
l'impression 3d qu'on s'affranchit des
contraintes de forme est contrainte de
forme pour les parfums et les briques
bas ça nous fait faire des murs droit
aujourd'hui on est libéré de sa donc les
géométries les plus pertinentes à
construire pour que ce soit solide et
que ça résiste à l'environnement c'est
plutôt des dom d'où un petit peu le
modèle de cette maison on en a d'autres
en stock
vous en verrez peut-être tout à l'heure
l'enjeu avec ça donc c'est travailler
autour puis après de sortir la maison
une fois terminée et si on arrive à
imprimer demain avec un matériau trouvé
en cycle court alors là la maison
impasse de 5000 euros en béton à zéro ou
presque zéro c'est ce que jeremy rifkin
dans la troisième révolution
industrielle appelle le zéro coût
marginal
c'est qu'à la fin en fait la machine
elle est là elle travaille de prendre la
terre sûr il reste énergie matières et
idées c'est les seuls coups qu'on a donc
la machine elle est là l'énergie solaire
a priori vu les projets
d'électrification de troisième
révolution industrielle qui existe et
solaire l'énergie
vous l'avez la matière si on prend la
terre sur place c'est gratuit aussi où
quasiment gratuit élie desbin
on la donne l'enjeu c'est de faire ça
alors aujourd'hui
moi j'ai 31 ans j'ai 20 ans devant moi
et je prends un peu à paris avec vous
c'est d'essayer de voir dans vingt ans
où on en sera pour ceux qui seront là et
j'espère que vous serez tous le le sujet
aujourd'hui intéressant au lieu si vous
voulez j'ai je travaille aujourd'hui
alors on est une petite équipe on n'est
pas non plus pléthore et on fait ça avec
les obligés et puis on commença à
fédérer des institutions nous on
aimerait bien porter ce message le plus
haut possible
on aimerait bien pouvoir va
industralisés une production et faire
profiter et on a déjà des associations
qui sont très demandeuses de ce type de
matériel pour pouvoir lutter contre le
milliard le milliard de gens qui n'ont
pas de maison donc tout le projet c'est
d'essayer déjà un d'armes et les
associations avec du matériel de les
former pourquoi pas de les fabriquer ici
aussi et de de compte faire comprendre
et c'est ma chance c'est que non
seulement une convergence technologique
mais on a aussi une convergence des
idées si vous voulez aujourd'hui on sent
que c'est possible de faire ce que je
vous ai montré mais il ya aussi l'être
humain qui commencent à comprendre que
c'est indispensable
vous avez les réfugiés en pagaille
depuis des mois sur nos écrans j'ai
entendu certains nicolas hulot ce matin
qui avait osé
on est vraiment dans ce moment où il
faut pousser ce genre d'idées alors il
ya la coop 21 il ya plein de
d'événements de ce type là qui qui sont
en train de pousser mais moi ce que j'ai
envie ce soir c'est que ben on se dise
rendez vous dans vingt ans et puis on
pousse à et d'ici 20 ans moi j'ai j'ai
qu'une envie c'est qu'on ait fait le
plus de maisons possible dans des pays
donc là on allait
philippines on a on à l'inde en a le
mali et le bénin qui sont déjà des
plateformes où on a des gens qui sont
intéressés d'avoir ça alors n'est pas
prêt tout de suite mais j'espère que
l'année prochaine on aura déjà des
essais sur ce territoire là et qu'on
pourra pousser pousser pousser cette
solution avec le plus de gens autour de
nous alors on a réussi à fédérer pas mal
de deux d'entreprise des petites
entreprises vous imaginez que les gros
et bien qu'il voulait me piquer l'idée
et y ont peut pas encore les accepter et
donc bah voilà on a poussé l'idée avec
des écoles on a poussé l'idée avec des
entreprises et aujourd'hui on va essayer
de synthétiser tout ça est de garder le
plus longtemps possible si possible tant
que je serai là le côté social
collaboratif de cette idée et c'est bien
ce qui nous protégera de deux des gens
qui n'ont pas envie de faire ça une idée
sociale collaboratif en fait tant que
l'idée sera partagée il faut comprendre
qu'elle sera enfin qu'on sera pas
concurrence à blanc fait les chinois
aujourd'hui ils font une idée afin
qu'ils ont imprimé des maisons vous avez
sans doute entendu parler
un état un bâtiment de cinq étages et en
personne vit dedans ça y est encore très
très politique comme projet mais ils
n'ont pas compris la troisième
révolution industrielle au sens propre
c'est à dire qu'un déjà ils font pour
gagner de l'argent
bon ça on peut comprendre quand on est
dans la deuxième révolution industrielle
ont ils le font avec des matériaux pas
propre il a dû vente à l'amiante pour
vous dire on a récupéré des morceaux de
caoutchouc eux on les a analysés et ils
contiennent de l'amiante pour ça ils
peuvent le changez vous me direz et
dernièrement ils font une usine dans
lequel il imprime la maison après la
coupe en morceaux il à mettre sur des
camions et après il l'envoie sur
chantier larrea semble donc ils ont
inventé un mode de préfabrication
tout l'enjeu ici en europe c'est de
faire bien mieux c'est de profiter de
nos compétences de le faire en local
parce qu'il a toutes les compétences
notre chance dans la région c'est qu'on
a des écoles multiples de toutes
compétences ingénierie design vous en
avez ici une de 800 étudiants
donc voilà c'est c'est sur ce choeur et
sur cette audace qu'on a envie de
pousser un projet qui je l'espère peut
changer
le monde voilà j'espère que ça ça vous
plaît et que vous serez aussi à votre
niveau
porteur de cette idée ou du moins si ça
vous a plu vous l'art l'airé et plus on
sera relayé plus on sera entendu et plus
on aura des moyens pour pouvoir pousser
cette idée merci